[Applause]
desperation is growing in tapachula on
wednesday hundreds of migrants mainly
from haiti and central america took to
the streets in protest
they're frustrated over mexican
government policy that prevents them
from leaving the city
we just want to get out because we're
not here to stay we're just going
through we have no money no food nothing
we're in prison here without anything
and the government does not help
some protesters are parents with
children who say the city is overcrowded
and food and shelter are becoming harder
to find
with my children it's very difficult
there are no jobs no food we're living
on the street we have many problems i
have nothing we need help
since the start of the year the number
of migrants arriving in southern mexico
has only grown and so have tensions
between them and authorities
this cannot be happening it's like we
just came from africa in chains like
modern day slaves in a democracy
everybody has to be free
with shelters for migrants and asylum
seekers already over capacity many say
their patience has run out
demonstrations like this one with
hundreds of migrants blocking off
traffic have become quite commonplace
here in tapachula and local residents
tell us that this is the worst migrant
crisis the city has experienced in
recent memory
an estimated 40 000 migrants are
currently stuck in tapachula some have
been here for months and more continue
to arrive every day
i call president lopez obrador to stop
being a puppet of the united states to
stop being the guard dog of the united
states to follow mexican law and stop
repressing the migrant population
stop beating up migrants
stop combating and treating migrants
like criminals
despite the mexican government's
strategy to contain migrants in the
southern part of the country experts
warn the impact on overall migrant
numbers reaching the u.s southern border
is negligible
instead the policy of limiting their
mobility has only turned the city of
tapachula into a pressure cooker and
tensions are ready to explode
manuel rapalo al jazeera tapachula
mexico